[Music]
do you think
about the tent of september fabio ziggo
ben my trip and my guest and the
mie who gets czech republic and will
decide to try to live in different
country and the three sides true to
change our professions and de het  was so
her home who you want
religious freemake he who choose and the
the nash day to the elephant of september
am in 5 years ago from academy and
clean to less term and
is now the tasker it was it is do
you will and bio and the
the garden and the student who turns me
decision and the and what have you this and the
internet incense understand who wants to
break off
yes and the this boar and re-leaf it seems
the money
this country czech republic which
really it also gets you not  your goal in front of the
door and own the budget you tomake
my movie in this country and the off the
fun do the tank chalk sting with ok
replaces which support
supporten at home and the tres at home and the
echo in keyboard off
yes and he won when he  want i do think o
was coo  l
van mook burglary film score spot and the
box and the lions
jeans things hear i and the a really think
that the is going to become this space and the
for those who have on bottle want to
import songs and from surprise and the y
right to think how we teachers  who
responds work i still have money and the
out it seems henk alexandra
vegetables where how
support my film now and then is caring
about this tradition and it seems
inc
they are there to keep you out of your weapon producer and
the show
with  take it to your dear juni you have this
for a movie you will get it
that smell and the moi c'est have to give
this from share and the iphone to dig
and think producer martin van so
for here
gently providers to the
professional this was  really think for want i
also much surprised and the
out it seems also reminds about
looks a dream of course alexandre
closet you for here
she was so strict is a professional and
the switch patient and side is my guest
are
something wit hi  j take product code or the
members of my team and really think you are
going to support a little bit million money to
make this movie and habit think my
prince with me just i watch this my
movie and the island am scared for the
lesson and then proteins  think academy
it's days will it ching stumping in
mee and the out link
it's it's incredible utterance i
want cold min flash and the there a link
for thinking demi loss and for
this week i got you out went sun and
dinners and yesterday  tenner summer and the
near real i i the basques my team
for games you to support to standup
and you dare and who came applause in this
place to my pink is summer
camping